you
architecture is a social art it requires
the orchestration of many disciplines
technological social political cultural
to design out-of-the-box to stretch the
boundaries of common practice a design
must be compelling to the public it must
uplift the spirit and be convincing to
the people who follow you
you
with marina bay sands I wanted to create
a mixing bowl between Singapore and the
world a place for Singaporeans meet
tourists and visitors and the visitors
meet Singapore unhappy that since its
opening marina basis has already become
the icon for Singapore identified around
the world and embraced by its own
citizens
the
one likes to say design is problem
solving this sounds however as if we
mean dealing mostly with functional
issues but this is only part of the
story architects must seek to elevate
and inspire uplift people's hopes and
expectations it must seek the magic of
being memorable and meaningful that is
where the mystery of design lives